a tale as old as time sounds romantic
but if it hadn't been changed to the
Disney movie we know in love there's a
good chance you might not be as much of
a beauty in the beasts fan keep watching
to find out how Belle was meant to ease
the fear of an arranged marriage if
you're new here make sure to subscribe
to the things and give our video a big
thumbs up now let's check out the
disturbing real story behind Beauty and
the Beast
the recent Beauty and the Beast
live-action movie features one of
Hollywood's most beloved feminists Emma
Watson it's difficult not to look for
elements of equality in a movie that
continues to be such a big part of our
childhoods however like any narrative
it's important to examine where the
story comes from if anything unveiling
the story's darker past might even add
to our current appreciation of the film
and the corresponding adjustments and
tweaks the story has undergone
throughout its life not always so strong
and independent there are a lot of
misconceptions when it comes to our
interpretations of the love story
between Belle and the Beast
for example mini fans perceive Belle's
ability to make her own decisions as a
sign of her independence
like when she courageously sets out to
save her father this is impressive for a
Disney Princess as she strives to defy
the patriarchy that tries to limit her
usefulness to solely her good looks some
have gone as far as viewing Belle as a
feminist character though this may be
true for our perspective in our current
social climate the tale originated as
part of the oral storytelling tradition
this would have been decades prior to
any social or civil rights movement
making it impossible for Belle to be a
feminist in her cultural and historical
context where does the story come from
looking at where the story of Beauty and
the Beast originated is very helpful in
understanding how far our interpretation
of Belle has come a professor of
folklore and mythology Marie Tator
explained how this contextual change
happened Tator divulged in a grammar
interview that the story of Beauty and
the Beast has existed among communities
for longer than we can track the story
we know and love was first published in
print by French author Madame Gabrielle
Suzanne Davalloo in this version Belle
is a good fairy and a descendant of a
key
this tell was based on the real story of
Petrus Gonsalves and his bride Katherine
Petrus was afflicted by a condition
called hypertrichosis which caused
excessive hair growth all over his body
he was initially adopted by the French
royal family for their amusement Petrus
would go on to marry Katherine and they
became a celebrity couple so using them
as inspiration for a printed version of
the existing oral tell makes sense after
all people want to read about things
they have experience with however it was
a French author Jean Marie lip prints de
Beaumont who wrote a second print
version of the fairy tale Beaumont
version was meant to serve as a lesson
for girls ranging from ages as young as
5 to 13 her goal was not to empower
young women and inspire them to make
their own decisions quite the opposite
Beauty and the Beast was meant to prove
to young 18th century readers that
arranged marriages aren't as bad as they
may seem for a girl a potential husband
who was older and much hairier would not
be so unlike the Beast Belle eventually
falls for by the time it was rewritten
by Beaumont Belle was no longer royalty
but instead the daughter of an inventor
the purpose of this was to ensure that
the story would be relatable to a French
population that was becoming
increasingly frustrated by the growth of
an aristocratic class the story was then
interpreted into the version we know
best by English author named Andrew Lang
this version was the most popular as it
was translated into several languages
and served as the inspiration for movies
and songs the Disney version finally in
the most recent live-action film
director Bill Condon added another
modification in this version Belle is an
inventor who creates a washing machine
to provide her with more time for
reading the nature of the invention has
also been criticized as relying too
heavily on gender roles we can use this
as a true testament of how far audiences
have come the Disney animated and
live-action narrative suggests that
Belle makes an independent decision to
save her father and sacrifices her own
freedom in exchange the Beast depicted
as angry and violent eventually succumbs
Seville's intelligence and kindness and
they find a love that transcends
appearance this is not the case in the
original story instead bellison to live
with the beat
who is more attractive and offers her
any luxuries she desires by the end of
the story she accepts her situation and
falls in love with the creature she's
been destined to marry this would not
have been too unlike young girls who
were forced to marry older men
another theory presented by tater is
that the beast serves as a metaphor for
fear itself following this logic the
beast is a representation of Belle's
fears once she confronts these fears and
fills at peace with them she is able to
see the beast for who he is as her
judgement is no longer clouded by her
concerns essentially through the scary
image of the Beast the audience is
supposed to learn that the worst part of
being held captive against your will is
your fear once you move past that you
will see that life isn't as bad as it
seems
Disney found a way to flip this on its
head making sure that the beasts
insecurities were the reason for his
harsh attitude towards the rest of
society that had exiled him the take
away on one hand Disney is advocating
for a feminist rendition of Beauty and
the Beast on the other hand we may
continue to find fault in the
problematic power dynamics that prevail
in all retellings of the story
nevertheless the movie continues to
bring up important questions about what
it means to be in a healthy relationship
as long as it's properly contextualized
for a young audience presenting
difficult and uncomfortable narratives
from an outdated literary tradition that
might cause us to continue to question
the gender roles we still take for
granted according to Disney Belle's
compassion and intelligence allows
beasts to show himself for who he is
instead of Belle having to accept her
situation she helps the Beast confront
his own issues and become a better
version of himself somehow Disney has
successfully turned a story about female
oppression in arranged marriages into an
inspiring lesson about seeing others for
who they truly are that's it for our
video don't forget to subscribe to the
things and hit that like button for more
videos like this one see you next time
[Music]